ben tre
[拍手]
皆さんは
変人ですか
あの返しそうそうこいつは痛いなーに言ってんだというちょっと微妙な空気感が流れて
いますが
今日はですね僕の投稿通じて
あの皆さんにお伝えしたいのは
変人の面白さについてです
ひょっとすると僕のトークが終わる頃には皆さんは変人の魅力に取り憑かれているかも
しれませんよ
僕のいう変人とは一体どういう意味なのか
それはこのトークの最後にお伝えするので頭の片隅に置いて聴いていてくださいね
お気づきの方もいらっしゃるかもしれないんですけど僕
ちょっと変わってるんですねあの周りの高校生ではまあなかなかやらないような変わっ
たことをやってしまうんです
例えば僕抹茶アイスが大好きなんですね
大好きなんですで
その抹茶アイスを食べる瓶だけに本場京都へ
丸11かけて友達と一緒に100キロもの道のりを自転車で行きました
また中学校の文化祭では史上初となる
dj イベントを開催しもう先生や友達と大フィーバーしたあどうもうとにかく
いろんなことにチャレンジするのが大好きなんです
今日はそんなチャレンジ大好きな僕が歩んできた
返事いない
変人の面白さについて少しお話ししたいと思います
さかのぼること2年前
僕は高校受験を控えていて
世界とつながれるような高校に行っていろんなことに挑戦しようと思い
グローバルな活動ができる高校に入学しようと挑戦しました
すごく入念に対策を積みましたが
落ちました
2回挑戦するチャンスがあったんですけど
2回とも落ちてしまったんです
その時はショックのあまり生まれて初めて
人前で号泣してしまいました
けど
僕はう
まあ
ここであきらめちゃいけないとどこの学校に行っても自分のやりたいことは絶対に
あきらめずに挑戦しようと思い気持ちを切り替えて
今通っている高校で独自に挑戦しています
高校に入学して僕が最初に挑戦したこと
それは日本ユネスコ協会連盟が主催する
カンボジア研修会の応募です
実は中学生の時に授業の中でカンボジアの抱える貧困問題について学んだことを
きっかけに
カンボジアの現状をこの目で直接見て学びたいと思うようになりました
そのことを実現しようと思ったんです
実はこの研修は全国で10人しか選ばれないんですよ
なので僕もこれまで以上に努力して準備を進めて
そしてなんと代表に選んでもらうことができたんです
この時も僕はもう嬉しさままにもう家で泣きながらもを撮りまくってましたもう嬉し
すぎてほんとにもう
母に嬉しかったです
そうして僕はカンボジア現地
を迎えました
現地ではさまざまな人との出会いがあり
歴史や文化カンボジアの抱える課題など
直接見て学ぶことができました
その中でも
一番
心に残っている出来事が
ユネスコの教育室税あるて楽園に通う
ある女の子との出会いです
実家と離ればでわずかな収入を頼りに暮らしている彼女に僕はある質問しました
将来を夢は何
すると
彼女はこう答えました
私は
お医者さんになりたい
私の暮らす村にはお医者さんが少なくてくる新ルール村の人がたくさんいる
だから
私が寺子屋でたくさん勉強してお医者さんになって
村の人たちを作りたい
そして
そのお金で
をとうとう学校に行かせてあげたい
彼女は当時
僕と同じ
15歳です
僕は
衝撃を受けました
彼女はテストでいい点を取るためでもなく良い大学に行くために学んでいるわけでは
ありません
日本と比べて劣悪とも言える環境の中で学んでいる
けれども
地域の為家族の為自分の将来のために学んでいるんだという高い志を胸に学んでいる姿
がそこにはありました
この出会いから
僕は
学ぶことに対してもっと自分にしかない
志をもって学んでいく姿勢が僕たち私たちには必要なのではないかなと強く感じました
この学びをより多くの人に届けようと思い
僕はさらなる挑戦をしました
ワンワールドフェスティバルという西日本最大の国際問題を学ぶ場での発表
世界遺産学習全国サミットでの実践報告
母校への出前授業や
どうせ大会語る機会などもあり学びを多くの人に発信することができました
実は初めて発表したとき僕は話を聞いてもらえるのかとても不安でした
っていうのも目の前に座っている男の子がキーだか様に眠った層にも甘いも今すぐ寝て
しまいそうな感じになっていて
この時はこれはマジでヤバいなと
もう危機感を感じていたんですけどでもその男の子の女が途中から
武井んとっ
目が開いてきて
最後には目を爛々と
はやかせて話を聞いてくれたときには
ものすごく
感動しました
こうした活動を通じて
人により学びを伝えることって楽しいんだってことに僕は気づくことができました
僕の中だけの学びにとどまらせるのではなくその学びを周りの人にも伝えていくと自分
も周りもより成長し変化することができたのです
こうやって
幅広く挑戦する1年生を
僕は過ごしていました
でも
実はこれだけじゃないんです
実は1年生の夏にカンボジア研修と並行して街づくり甲子園にも挑戦していたです
これは島根県隠岐島に全国から地域活性化に興味のある高校生が集い
まちづくりに対する考えを深め合う
大会です
実はこの沖ノ島は数年前までは過疎化で悩む地域でしたが
ちま全体の教育改革に取り組み
なんと若者率を v 字回復した地域なんです
この場所で学べたことが地域創造において大切なことを学ぶきっかけになりました
そこではより良い島にしようと本当に努力している
島の方がたくさんいて僕は全国の高校生と熱く語り合っていく中で
まちづくりは人づくりだということを学ぶことができました
どれだけおいし素晴らしい風景やおいしいご飯やお土産があったとしてもそこにその
地域に暮らす人がいないと
その魅力にはならない
まちづくりにはその地域に暮らす人が一番重要だということを肌で感じることができ
ました
そうこうしているうちに僕は高校2年生
なりました
2年生になってよしもうともっと挑戦しようと思い
よっしゃいいなやってみようと思っていた矢先
コロナが
やってきてしまいました
学校も休校となり様々な活動が自粛となってしまいました
でも僕がそんなことでが極めたりしませんでした
心の中で何もできないからこそ僕は新しいことに挑戦しました
僕はですねもう家にいるだけでうずうずしていたので
ねえ課長さんできることはないかなと
考えていたところ
田んぼ茶屋
沖ノ島での人との交流を通じて
人の暮らしや教育現場にも必ずビジネスや経営が関わっていたことを思い出しました
そこで
b リストを学んでみるかどう
思いたちましてですねネットで見つけ出した
オンラインでのビジネスコンテストに出場しました
そのコンテストは大学生方向性とグループを組み
起業家な方とのマッチングを得て1週間でビジネスプランを構築するというものですあ
ちなみにあの
ですねそこでですね僕は日本史を海外展開する新規事業を立ち上げようという日本史を
テーマにしたビジネスプランを立ち上げました
ちなみにっぽく日本酒飲んでないんで安心してくださいね高校生なんでうぬ船2本市の
魅力
を生かしてグローバルに展開するようなプランを
考えるのはとても難しかったですが
チームで協力して仮説検証を繰り返し日本史の良さを生かしたプランを練り上げました
独自のアイディアとチームでの活動を評価していただけて最終最優秀賞をいただくこと
ができました
まさか受賞するとは思いもしなかったので本当に嬉しかったです
この挑戦は
これを中だからこそ考えつくことができ
オンラインによるビジネスの可能性を感じ取ることができました
大学生や起業家の方ともディスカッションを重ね
様々な経験を積んでいる人と深め合っていくからこそ
有意義なものを作り上げることができました
さらに僕はカンボジア研修を通じて右染みた英語力のなさを鍛え上げるためによし
もっと実践的な英語力を身につけようとオンラインで世界中の学生とつながるオン
ラインサマースクールにチャレンジしました
実際にオールイングリッシュで海外の大学生とディスカッションをするなど実用的な
英語を交えたコミュニケーションに触れることができ
アクティブリー学ぶことができました
何よりも
日本中
世界中に友達がたくさんできてグローバルな視野を身に付けられたことが
僕の中での大きな
変化でした
さて
もうこれぐらいだと思うじゃないですか
違うんです
実は遅く高校では
演劇るに入って言うんですもうこの演劇がもう楽しくて楽しくて仕方ないんですよ
もう部活の仲間も本当に個性豊か0
大好きなんです
その仲間と一緒にコロナという逆風に立ち向かえながら作品を作り上げてきました
そして県大会で優勝しなんと近畿大会に出場することが決まったんです
そしてですねその近畿大飼はなんと
昨日だったんですあのですねまだ筋肉痛が残っていますちょっと
ですねちょっとハードスケジュールすぎましたねあっはぁ
はい最新の挑戦です
僕はこの演劇を通じて
人を幸せにすることの喜びを学ぶことができました
自分たちで一生懸命に作った作品をお客様に披露する
そして終演後にはお客様と一緒に笑顔になれる
自分たちの努力が人の幸せに結びつくということを
実感できたんです
そしていろんなことをやっている中でとあるショックなニュースが僕の耳に届きました
それはコロナの影響でカンボジア研修が中止になってしまったことです
今年度のカンボジア懸賞に応募しようと心に決めていた
僕の友達がいたのですか
その友達の思いも
実現しないこととなってしまいました
自分に何かできることはないと
考えていました
すると
オンラインビジネスコンテスト
オンライン様スクールっ
学びがー
繋がったんです
ひらめいだ
そう
オンラインカンボジア研修を開催しようといいですね
僕はさっそく感も同じカンボジア研修に参加した仲間に声をかけ
企画書を作り日本ユネスコ協会連盟に企画提案を
を行いましたそして南と北に想いが届き実技
にこぎつけることができたんです
そうして来週の30日に史上初の開催となる
オンラインカンボジア研修を実施します
こうやって
僕は様々なことに挑戦してきました
でも
すべての挑戦が
決して
円滑に進んでいたわけではありません
調整の中には
苦悩も
挫折も
たくさんありました
自分だけの力ではどうにもできない解決だ息できないこともありました
僕自身も高校受験で失敗したときは
これからどうしようという
病んでました
けど今思えば
この出来事があったからこそ今の僕があるんです
そうして悩みや挫折を乗り越えていくことがだんだんだんだん楽しくなってきたんです
悩みを乗り越えた時視野がバーッと広がってあとは自然に前に進んでいくんです
自分が挑戦していくことで明らかに
周りが変化していっ
そうして振り返ると
自分
なんか成長できたなっぺ
思えるんです
それに
挑戦をすることで本当にいろんな人との出会いができます
その出会いはもっともっとその人から学びたいという思い
つながってさらなる挑戦へとつながります
大きな挫折があったからこそ
今の自分へ変わるきっかけが
生まれたんです
うまくいかなかったから
諦めるものでは
うまくいかないときこそもがき続けることで
ピンチを
ジャズに
することができるんです
をして
大きく
演歌できます
さて
僕は
変人というキーワードを
冒頭で言いました
どうですか
新人って何かわかりましたか
この変人
ただの変わった人という意味ではないんですね
僕のいう変人の本当の意味
それは
変化できる人という意味です
ボクは常に変わりたい変化したいと思って挑戦をしているそれをしているから今の僕の
人生は最高に楽しいですそうして気づけば僕だけじゃなくて周りも
マッティになっていました
僕は変人であり続けたい
だからこれをキーワードに挑戦し続けています
挑戦を通じて僕はたくさんの人と
つながれた
だからこそたくさんのことを
学ぶことが
できたんです
挑戦するって
道に枝
楽しいんです
今日
ここに立って話しているのも僕の挑戦の一つです
皆さんに伝えていくなかれ
僕自身も学びたいからこそここに立っている
僕はこれからも変人に何続けたい
よかったら
あなたの
変人になってみませんか
ありがとうございました
[拍手]